The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JAMES SWAN: OK.
Well, everyone's
quieted down, so that
means we have to get started.
So let me say something here.
This will be our
last conversation
about optimization.
So we've discussed
unconstrained optimization.
And now we're going to discuss
a slightly more complicated
problem-- but
you're going to see
it's really not that
much more complicated--
constrained optimization.
These are the things
we discussed before.
I don't want to spend
much time recapping
because I want to take a minute
and talk about the midterm
exam.
So we have a quiz.
It's next Wednesday.
Here's where it's
going to be located.
Here's 66.
Head down Ames.
You're looking for Walker
Memorial on the third floor.
Unfortunately, the time for
the quiz is 7:00 to 9:00 PM.
We really did try hard
to get the scheduling
office to give us
something better,
but the only way to get a room
that would fit everybody in
was to do it at
this time in Walker.
I really don't understand,
because I actually
requested locations for
the quizzes back in April.
And somehow I was
too early, maybe,
and got buried under a pile.
Maybe not important
enough, I don't know.
But it's got to be from
seven to nine next Wednesday.
Third floor.
There's not going
to be any class
next Wednesday because
you have a quiz instead.
So you get a little extra time
to relax or study, prepare,
calm yourself before
you go into the exam.
There's no homework this week.
So you can just use this time
to focus on the material we've
discussed.
There's a practice
exam from last year
posted on the Steller site,
which you can utilize and study
from.
I'll tell you this.
That practice exam is
skewed a little more
towards some chemical
engineering problems
that motivate the numerics.
I've found in the past that
when problems like that
are given on the exam,
sometimes there's
a lot of reading that goes into
understanding the engineering
problem.
And that tends to set
back the problem-solving.
So I'll tell you that the quiz
that you'll take on Wednesday
will have less of the
engineering associated with it,
and focus more on the numerical
or computational science.
The underlying
sorts of questions,
the way the questions are
asked, the kinds of responses
you're expected to give
I'd say are very similar.
But we've tried to tune
the exam so that it'll
be less of a burden
to understand
the structure of the
problem before describing
how you'd solve it.
So I think that's good.
It's comprehensive up to today.
So linear algebra, systems
of nonlinear equations
and optimization
are the quiz topics.
We're going to switch on
Friday to ordinary differential
equations and initial
value problems.
So you have two
lectures on that,
but you won't have
done any homework.
You probably don't know enough
or aren't practiced enough
to answer any questions
intelligently on the quiz.
So don't expect that
material to be on there.
It's not.
It's going to be
these three topics.
Are there any questions
about this that I can answer?
Kristin has a question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SWAN: OK.
So yeah, come prepared.
It might be cold.
It might be hot.
It leaks when it
rains a little bit.
Yeah, it's not
the greatest spot.
So come prepared.
That's true.
Other questions?
Things you want to know?
AUDIENCE: What can
we take to the exam?
JAMES SWAN: Ooh, good question.
So you can bring the book
recommended for the course.
You can bring your notes.
You can bring a calculator.
You need to bring some pencils.
We'll provide blue books for
you to write your solutions
to the exam in.
So those are the materials.
Good.
What else?
Same question.
OK.
Other questions?
No?
OK.
So then let's jump into
the topic of the day, which
is constrained optimization.
So these are
problems of the sort.
Minimize an objective function
f of x subject to the constraint
that x belongs to some set
D, or find the argument
x that minimizes this function.
These are equivalent
sorts of problem.
Sometimes, we want to know
one or the other or both.
That's not a problem.
And graphically,
it looks like this.
Here's f, our
objective function.
It's a nice convex
bowl-shaped function here.
And we want to know the
values of x1 and x2,
let's say, that
minimize this function
subject to some constraint.
That constraint could
be that x1 and x2 live
inside this little blue circle.
It could be D. It could
be that x1 and x2 live
on the surface of
this circle, right,
on the circumference
of this circle.
That could be the constraint.
So these are the sorts of
problems we want to solve.
D is called the
feasible set, and can
be described in terms of really
two types of constraints.
One is what we call
equality constraints.
So D can be the set
of values x such
that some nonlinear function
c of x is equal to zero.
So it's the set of points
that satisfy this nonlinear
equation.
And among those
points, we want to know
which one produces the minimum
in the objective function.
Or it could be an
inequality constraint.
So D could be the set of
points such that some nonlinear
function h of x is, by
convention, positive.
So h of x could
represent, for example,
the interior of a
circle, and c of x
could represent the
circumference of a circle.
And we would have
nonlinear equations
that reflect those
values of x that satisfy
those sorts of geometries.
So equality constrained,
points that lie on this circle,
inequality constrained, points
that lie within this circle.
The shape of the feasible set
is constrained by the problem
that you're actually
interested in.
So it's easy for me to
draw circles in the plane
because that's a shape
you're familiar with.
But actually, it'll
come from some sort
of physical constraint on the
engineering problem you're
looking at, like mole fractions
need to be bigger than zero
and smaller than one, and
temperatures in absolute value
have to be bigger than zero
and smaller than some value
because that's a safety
factor on the process.
So these set up the
constraints on various sorts
of optimization problems
that we're interested in.
It could also be true that
we're interested in, say,
optimization in the domain
outside of this circle, too.
It could be on the inside,
could be on the outside.
That's also an inequality
constrained sort of problem.
You know some of these already.
They're familiar to you.
So here's a classic
one from mechanics.
Here's the total energy in a
system for, say, a pendulum.
So x is like the position of
the tip of this pendulum and v
is the velocity
that it moves with.
This is the kinetic energy.
This is the potential energy.
And we know the pendulum
will come to rest in a place
where the energy is minimized.
Well, the energy can
only be minimized
when the velocity here is zero,
because any non-zero velocity
will always push the
energy content up.
So it comes to rest.
It doesn't move.
And then there's some
value of x at which
the energy is minimized.
If there is no constraint
that says that the pendulum is
attached to some
central axis, then I
can always make
the energy smaller
by making x more
and more negative.
It just keeps falling.
There is no stopping point.
But there's a constraint.
The distance between
the tip of the pendulum
and this central point is
some fixed distance out.
So this is an equality
constrained sort of problem,
and we have to choose
from the set of v
and x the values subject
to this constraint that
minimize the total energy.
And that's this configuration
of the pendulum here.
So you know these sorts
of problems already.
We talked about this one,
linear sorts of programs.
These are optimization problems
where the objective function is
linear in the design variables.
So it's just the dot product
between x and some vector
c that weights the
different design
options against each other.
So we talked about ice cream.
Yes, this is all
premium ice cream
because it comes in
the small containers,
subject to different
constraints.
So those constraints
can be things
like, oh, x has to be
positive because we can't make
negative amounts of ice cream.
And maybe we've
done market research
that tells us that
the market can only
tolerate certain ratios of
different types of ice cream.
And that may be some
set of linear equations
that describe that market
research that sort of bound
the upper values of
how much ice cream
we can put out on the market.
And then we try to choose the
optimal blend of pina colada
and strawberry to sell.
So those are linear programs.
This is an inequality
constrained optimization.
In general, we might write
these problems like this.
We might say minimize f of
x subject to the constraint
that c of x is 0 and
h of x is positive.
So minimize it over
the values of x that
satisfy these two constraints.
There's an old approach that's
discussed in the literature.
And it's not used.
I'm going to describe
it to you, and then I
want you to try to figure
out why it's not used.
And it's called
the penalty method.
And the penalty
method works this way.
It says define a new
objective function,
which is our old objective
function plus some penalty
for violating the constraints.
How does that penalty work?
So we know that we want
values of x for which c of x
is equal to 0.
So if we add to our objective
function the norm of c of x--
this is a positive quantity--
this is a positive
quantity-- whenever
x doesn't satisfy
the constraint,
this positive
quantity will give us
a bigger value for this
objective function f
than if c of x was equal to 0.
So we penalize points which
don't satisfy the constraint.
And in the limit that this
penalty factor mu here
goes to zero, the penalties
get large, so large
that our solution
will have to prefer
satisfying the constraints.
There's another penalty
factor over here,
which is identical to this
one but for the inequality
constraint.
It says take a
heaviside step function
for which is equal to 1 when
the value of its argument
is positive, and
it's equal to zero
when the value of its
argument is negative.
So whenever I violate each
of my inequality constraints,
Hi of x, turn on this
heaviside step function,
make it equal to 1,
and then multiply it
by the value of the constraint
squared, a positive number.
So this is the inequality
constraint penalty,
and this is the equality
constraint penalty.
People don't use this, though.
It makes sense.
I take the limit
that mu goes to zero.
I'm going to have
to prefer solutions
that satisfy these constraints.
Otherwise, if I don't
satisfy these constraints,
I could always move
closer to a solution that
satisfies the
constraint, and I'll
bring down the value of
the objective function.
I'll make it lower.
So I'll always prefer these
lower value solutions.
But can you guys take a second
and sort of talk to each other?
See if you can figure out why
one doesn't use this method.
Why is this method a problem?
OK, I heard the volume go
up at some point, which
means either you
switched topics and felt
more comfortable
talking about that
than this, or maybe
you guys were coming
to some conclusions, or
had some ideas about why
this might be a bad idea.
Do you want to volunteer some
of what you were talking about?
Yeah, Hersh.
AUDIENCE: Could it
be that [INAUDIBLE]??
JAMES SWAN: Well, that's
an interesting idea.
So yeah, if we have a
non-convex optimization problem,
there could be some issues
with f of x, and maybe f
of x runs away so
fast that I can never
make the penalty big enough
to enforce the constraint.
That's actually a
really interesting idea.
And I like the idea of comparing
the magnitude of these two
terms.
I think that's on
the right track.
Were there some
other ideas about why
you might not do this?
Different ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SWAN: Well, you know,
that that's an interesting idea,
but actually the two
terms in the parentheses
here are both positive.
So they're only
going to be minimized
when I satisfy the constraints.
So the local minima of
the terms in parentheses
sit on or within the
boundaries of the feasible set
that we're looking at.
So by construction,
actually, we're
going to be able to satisfy
them because the local minima
of these points sits
on these boundaries.
These terms are minimized by
satisfying the constraints.
Other ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do your iterates
have to be feasible?
JAMES SWAN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Your iterates
don't have to be feasible?
JAMES SWAN: Ooh,
this is a good point.
The iterates-- this is an
unconstrained optimization
problem.
I'm just going to minimize
this objective function.
It's like what
Hersh said, I can go
anywhere I want in the domain.
I'm going to minimize
this objective function,
and then I'm going
to try to take
the limit as mu goes to zero.
The iterates don't
have to be feasible.
Maybe I can't even evaluate
f of x if the iterates aren't
feasible.
That's an excellent point.
That could be an issue.
Anything else?
Are there some other ideas?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SWAN: I think
that's a good point.
AUDIENCE: --boundary
from outside
without knowing what's inside.
JAMES SWAN: Short.
So you'll see, actually,
the right way to do this
is to use what's called
interior point methods, which
live inside the domain.
This is an excellent point.
There's another issue
with this that's
I think actually less subtle
than some of these ideas, which
they're all correct, actually.
These can be problems with
this sort of penalty method.
As I take the limit
that mu goes to zero,
the penalty function
becomes large for all points
outside the domain.
They can become larger
than f for those points.
And so there are
some practical issues
about comparing these two
terms against each other.
I may not have sufficient
accuracy, sufficient number
of digits to accurately add
these two terms together.
So I may prefer
to find some point
that lives on the boundary of
the domain as mu goes to zero.
But I can't
guarantee that it was
a minima of f on that domain,
or within that feasible set.
So a lot of practical
issues that suggest this
is a bad idea.
This is an old idea.
People knew this was
bad for a long time.
It seems natural, though.
It seems like a good
way to transform
from these constrained
optimization problems
to something we
know how to solve,
an unconstrained optimization.
But actually, it turns out
not to be such a great way
to do it.
So let's talk about
separating out
these two different
methods from each other,
or these two different problems.
Let's talk first about
equality constraints,
and then we'll talk about
inequality constraints.
So equality constrained
optimization problems
look like this.
Minimize f of x subject
to c of x equals zero.
And let's make it even easier.
Rather than having some vector
of equality constraints,
let's just have
a single equation
that we have to satisfy for
that equality constraint,
like the equation for a circle.
Solutions have to sit on the
circumference of a circle.
So one equation that
we have to satisfy.
You might ask again, what
are the necessary conditions
for defining a minimum?
That's what we used
when we had equality--
or when we had
unconstrained optimization.
First we had to define
what a minimum was,
and we found that minima
were critical points, places
where the gradient of the
objective function was zero.
That doesn't have
to be true anymore.
Now, the minima has to live on
this boundary of some domain.
It has to live in this set
of points c of x equals zero.
And the gradient of
f is not necessarily
zero at that minimal point.
But you might guess that
Taylor expansions are the way
to figure out what the
appropriate conditions
for a minima are.
So let's take f of x, and
let's expand it, do a Taylor
expansion in some direction, d.
So we'll take a step away
from x, which is small,
in some direction, d.
So f of x plus d is
f of x plus g dot
d, the dot product between
the gradient of f and d.
And at a minimum,
either the gradient
is zero or the gradient is
perpendicular to this direction
we moved in, d.
We know that because this
term is going to increase--
well, will change
the value of f of x.
It will either make
it bigger or smaller
depending on whether it's
positive or negative.
In either case, it
will say that this
point x can't be a minimum
unless this term is exactly
equal to zero in the limit
that d becomes small.
So either the gradient
is zero or the gradient
is orthogonal to this
direction d we stepped in.
And d was arbitrary.
We just said take a
step in a direction, d.
Lets take our
equality constraint
and do the same sort of
Taylor expansion, because we
know if we're searching for
a minima along this curve
c of x better be equal to zero.
It better satisfy
the constraint.
And also, c of x plus d, that
little step in the direction d,
should also satisfy
the constraint.
We want to study only the
feasible set of values.
So actually, d
wasn't arbitrary. d
had to satisfy this
constraint that, when
I took this little step, c of x
plus d had to be equal to zero.
So again, we'll take
now a Taylor expansion
of c of x plus d, which
is c of x plus grad
of c of x dotted with d.
And that implies that d must be
perpendicular to the gradient
of c of x, because c of
x plus d has to be zero
and c of x has to be zero.
So the gradient of c of x
dot d-- it's a leading order
has also got to
be equal to zero.
So d and the gradient
in c are perpendicular,
and d and the gradient
in g have to be
perpendicular at a minimum.
That's going to define the
minimum on this equality
constrained set.
Does that make sense?
c satisfies the
constraint, c plus d
satisfies the constraint.
If this is true, d has to be
perpendicular to the gradient
of c, g has to be perpendicular
to the gradient of d.
d is, in some sense,
arbitrary still.
d has to satisfy
condition that it's
perpendicular to
the gradient of c,
but who knows,
there could be lots
of vectors that are
perpendicular to the gradient
of c.
So the only generic
relationship between these two
we can formulate is g must be
parallel to the gradient of c.
g is perpendicular
to d, gradient
of c is perpendicular to d.
In the most generic
way, g and gradient of c
should be parallel
to each other,
because d I can
select arbitrarily
from all the vectors of
the same dimension as x.
If g is parallel to
the gradient of c,
then I can write that g
minus some scalar multiplied
by the gradient of
c is equal to zero.
That's an equivalent
statement, that g is parallel
to the gradient of c.
So that's a condition
associated with points
x that solve this equality
constrained problem.
The other condition
is that point x still
has to satisfy the
equality constraint.
But I introduced a new
unknown, this lambda,
which is called the
Lagrange multiplier.
So now I have one extra unknown,
but I have one extra equation.
Let me give you a graphical
depiction of this,
and then I'll write down
the formal equations again.
So let's suppose
we want to minimize
this parabolic function
subject to the constraint
that the solution
lives on the line.
So here's the contours
of the function,
and the solution has
to live on this line.
So I get to stand
on this line, and I
get to walk and walk and walk
until I can't walk downhill
anymore. and I've got to
turn and walk uphill again.
And you can see the point where
I can't walk downhill anymore
is the place where this
constraint is parallel
to the contour, or
where the gradient
of the objective
function is parallel
to the gradient
of the constraint.
So you can actually
find this point
by imagining yourself
moving along this landscape.
After I get to this point,
I start going uphill again.
So that's the method of
Lagrange multipliers.
Minimize f of x subject
to this constraint.
The solution is
given by the point x
at which the gradient is
parallel to the gradient of c,
and at which c is equal to zero.
And you solve this system
of nonlinear equations
for two unknowns.
One is x, and the other
is this unknown lambda.
How far stretched
is the gradient
in f relative to
the gradient in c?
So again, we've turned
the minimization problem
into a system of
nonlinear equations.
In order to satisfy the
equality constraint,
we've had to introduce
another unknown,
the Lagrange multiplier.
It turns out this solution
set, x and lambda,
is a critical point of
something called the Lagrangian.
It's a function f of x
minus lambda times c.
It's a critical point in x
and lambda of this nonlinear
function called the Lagrangian.
It's not a minimum of this
function, unfortunately.
It's a saddle point of the
Lagrangian, it turns out.
So we're trying to find a
saddle point of the Lagrangian.
Does this make sense?
Yes?
OK.
We've got to be
careful, of course.
Just like with
unconstrained optimization,
we actually have to check that
our solution is a minimum.
We can't take for
granted, we can't
suppose that our nonlinear
solver found a minimum
when it solved this equation.
Other critical points can
satisfy this equation, too.
So we've got to go back and try
to check robustly whether it's
actually a minimum.
But this is the method.
Introduce an additional unknown,
the Lagrange multiplier,
because you can
show geometrically
that the gradient of
the objective function
should be parallel to the
gradient of the constraint
at the minimum.
Does that make sense?
Does this picture make sense?
OK.
So you know how to solve
systems of nonlinear equations,
you know how to solve
constrained optimization
problems.
So here's f.
Here's c.
We can actually write out
what these equations are.
So you can show that the
gradient of x minus lambda
gradient of c, that's a vector,
2x1 minus lambda and 20x2
plus lambda.
And c is the equation
for this line
down here, so x1
minus x2 minus 3.
And that's all got
to be equal to zero.
In this case, this is just a
system of linear equations.
So you can actually
solve directly
for x1, x2, and lambda.
And it's not too difficult to
find the solution for all three
of these things by hand.
But in general, these
constraints can be nonlinear.
The objective function
doesn't have to be quadratic.
Those are the easiest
cases to look at.
And the same
methodology applies.
And so you should check
that you're able to do this.
This is the simplest possible
equality constraint problem.
You could do it by hand.
You should check that you're
actually able to do it,
that you understand the steps
that go into writing out
these equations.
Let's just take one
step forward and look
at a less generic
case, one in which
we have a vector valued
function that gives the equality
constraints instead.
So rather than one equation
we have to satisfy,
there may be many.
It's possible that the
feasible set doesn't
have any solutions in it.
It's possible that
there is no x that
satisfies all of these
constraints simultaneously.
That's a bad problem to have.
You wouldn't like to have
that problem very much.
But it's possible
that that's the case.
But let's assume that there are
solutions for the time being.
So there are x's that satisfy
the equality constraint.
Let's see if we can
figure out again
what the necessary conditions
for defining a minima are.
So same as before,
let's Taylor expand
f of x going in
some direction, d.
And let's make d
a nice small step
so we can just treat
the f of x plus d
as a linearized function.
So we can see again
that g has to be
perpendicular to this
direction, d, if we're
going to have a minima.
Otherwise, I could step
in some direction, d,
and I'll find either a
smaller value of f of x plus d
or a bigger value
of f of x plus d.
So g has to be
perpendicular to d.
And for the equality
constraints,
again, they all have to satisfy
this equality constraint
up there.
So c of x has to be equal
to zero, and c of x plus d
also has to be equal to zero.
And so if we take
a Taylor expansion
of c of x plus d,
about x, you'll
get c of x plus d
plus the Jacobian
of c, all the partial
derivatives of c with respect
to x, multiplied by d.
We know that c of x plus d
is zero, and c of x is zero,
so the directions, d, belong
to what set of vectors?
The null space.
So these directions have
to live in the null space
of the Jacobian of c.
So I can't step
in any direction,
I have to step in
directions that
are in the null space of c.
g is perpendicular
to d, as well.
And d belongs to
the null space of c.
In fact, you know that d
is perpendicular to each
of the rows of the Jacobian.
Right?
You know that?
I just do the matrix
vector product, right?
And so each element of
this matrix vector product
is the dot product of d with a
different row of the Jacobian.
So those rows are
a set of vectors.
Those rows describe the
range of J transpose,
or the row space of J. Remember
we talked about the four
fundamental
subspaces, and I said
we almost never use
those other ones,
but this is one
time when we will.
So those rows belong to
the range of J transpose,
or they belong to the
left null space of J.
I need to find a g,
a gradient, which
is always perpendicular to d.
And I know d is always
perpendicular to the rows of J.
So I can write g as a linear
superposition of the rows of J.
As long as g is a linear
superposition of the rows,
it'll always be
perpendicular to d.
Vectors from the null
space of a matrix
are orthogonal to vectors from
the row space of that matrix,
it turns out.
And they're orthogonal
for this reason.
So it tells us, if
Jd is zero, then
d belongs to the null space.
g is perpendicular to d.
That means I could write g
as a linear superposition
of the rows of J. So g belongs
to the range of J transpose,
or it belongs to
the row space of J.
Those are equivalent statements.
And therefore, I should
be able to write g
as a linear superposition
of the rows of J.
And one way to say
that is I should
be able to write
g as J transpose
times some other vector lambda.
That's an equivalent
way of saying
that g is a linear
superposition of the rows of J.
I don't know the
values of lambda.
So I introduced a
new set of unknowns,
a set of Lagrange multipliers.
My minima is going
to be found when
I satisfy this equation,
just like before,
and when I'm able to satisfy
all of the equality constraints.
How many Lagrange
multipliers do I have here?
Can you figure that out?
You can talk with your
neighbors if you want.
Take a couple minutes.
Tell me how many Lagrange
multipliers, how many elements
are in this vector lambda.
How many elements are in lambda?
Can you tell me?
Sam.
AUDIENCE: Same as the number
of equality constraints.
JAMES SWAN: Yes.
It's the same as the number
of equality constraints.
J came from the gradient of c.
It's the Jacobian of c.
So it has a number of columns
equal to the number of elements
in x, because I'm taking
partial derivatives with respect
to each element of
x, and has a number
of rows equal to the
number of elements of c.
So J transpose, I just
transpose those dimensions.
And lambda must have the
same number of elements
as c does in order to make
this product make sense.
So I introduce a new
number of unknowns.
It's equal to exactly the
number of equality constraints
that I had, which
is good, because I'm
going to make a system
of equations that
says g of x minus J
transpose lambda equals 0
and c of x equals 0.
And the number of equations
here is the number
of elements in x
for this gradient,
and the number of
elements in c for c.
And the number of
unknowns is the number
of elements in x, and the number
of elements in c associated
with the Lagrange multiplier.
So I have enough equations
and unknowns to determine
all of these things.
So whether I have one equality
constraint or a million
equality constraints,
the problem is identical.
We use the method of
Lagrange multipliers.
We have to solve an
augmented system of equations
for x and this projection on the
row space of J, which tells us
how the gradient is
stretched or made up,
composed of elements
of the row space of J.
These are the
conditions associated
with a minima in our
objective function
on this boundary dictated
by the equality constraint.
And of course, the solution
set is a critical point
of a Lagrangian, which is
f of x minus c dot lambda.
And it's not a minimum of
it, it's a critical point.
It's a saddle point, it turns
out, of this Lagrangian.
So we've got to check,
did we find a saddle point
or not when we find a solution
to this equation here.
But it's just a system
of nonlinear equations.
If we have some good initial
guess, what do we apply?
Newton-Raphson, converge
rate towards the solution.
If we don't have a
good initial guess,
we've discussed lots of methods
we could employ, like homotopy
or continuation
to try to develop
good initial guesses for
what the solution should be.
Are there any
questions about this?
Good.
OK.
So you go to Matlab
and you call fmincon,
do a minimization problem, and
you give it some constraints.
Linear constraints,
nonlinear constraints,
it doesn't matter actually.
The problem is the
same for both of them.
It's just a little bit easier
if I have linear constraints.
If this constraining function
is a linear function, then
the Jacobian I know.
It's the coefficient matrix
of this linear problem.
Now I only have to solve
linear equations down here.
So the problem is a little
bit simpler to solve.
So Matlab sort of
breaks these apart
so it can use different
techniques depending on which
sort of problem is posed.
But the solution
method is the same.
It does the method of
Lagrange multipliers
to find the solution.
OK?
Inequality constraints.
So interior point
methods were mentioned.
And it turns out this
is really the best
way to go about solving
generic inequality constrained
problems.
So the problems of
the sort minimize
f of x subject to
h of x is positive,
or at least not negative.
This is some
nonlinear inequality
that describes some domain
and its boundary in which
the solution has to live.
And what's done is to rewrite
as an unconstrained optimization
problem with a barrier
that's incorporated.
This looks a lot like
the penalty method,
but it's very different.
And I'll explain how.
So instead, we want to
minimize this f of x minus mu
times the sum of log of h,
each of these constraints.
If h is negative, we'll take the
log of the negative argument.
That's a problem
computationally.
So the best we could do
is approach the boundary
where h is equal to zero.
And as h goes to zero, the
log goes to minus infinity.
So this term tends to blow
up because I've got a minus
sign in front of it.
So this is sort
of like a penalty,
but it's a little different
because the factor in front
I'm actually going to take
the limit as mu goes to zero.
I'm going to take the limit
as this factor gets small,
rather than gets big.
The log will always
get big as I approach
the boundary of the domain.
It'll blow up.
So that's not a problem.
But I can take the limit that
mu gets smaller and smaller.
And this quantity here
will have less and less
of an impact on the shape of
this new objective function
and mu gets smaller and smaller.
The impact will only be
nearest the boundary.
Does that make sense?
So you take the limit
that mu approaches zero.
It's got to approach it
from the positive side, not
the negative side, so
everything behaves well.
And this is called an
interior point method.
So we have to determine the
minimum of this new objective
function for progressively
weaker barriers.
So we might start
with some value of mu,
and we might reduce
mu progressively
until we get mu
down small enough
that we think we've
converged to a solution.
So how do you do that reliably?
What's the procedure one uses
to solve a problem successively
for different parameter values?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SWAN: Yeah, it's
a homotopy, right?
You're just going to change
the value of this barrier
parameter.
And you're going
to find a minima.
And if you make a small change
in the barrier parameter,
that's going to serve as
an excellent initial guess
for the next value.
And so you're just going
to take these small steps.
And the optimization
routine is going
to carry you towards
the minimum in the limit
that mu goes to zero.
So you do this with homotopy.
Here's an example of this
sort of interior point
method, a trivial example.
Minimize x subject
to x being positive.
So we know the solution
lives where x equals zero.
But let's write this as
unconstrained optimization
using a barrier.
So minimize x minus
mu times log x.
Here's x minus mu times log x.
So out here, where x is
big, x wins over log x,
so everything starts
to look linear.
But as x become
smaller and smaller,
log x gets very negative, so
minus log x gets very positive.
And here's the log
creeping back up.
And as I decrease mu
smaller and smaller,
you can see the minima
of this function
is moving closer and
closer and closer to zero.
So if I take the limit
that mu decreases
from some positive
number towards zero,
eventually this minimum
is going to converge
to the minimum of the
constrained inequality,
constrained
optimization problem.
Make sense?
OK.
So we want to do this.
You can use any barrier
function you want.
Any thoughts on why a
logarithmic barrier is used?
No.
OK, that's OK.
So minus log is
going to be convex.
Log isn't convex, but minus
log is going to be convex.
So that's good.
If this function's convex,
then their combination's
going to be convex,
and we'll be OK.
But the gradient of the
log is easy to compute.
Grad log h is 1 over h grad h.
So if I know h, I know
grad h, it's easy for me
to compute the
gradient of log h.
We know we're going to solve
this unconstrained optimization
problem where we need to take
grad of this objective function
equal zero.
So the calculations are easy.
The log makes it easy like that.
The log is also like
the most weakly singular
function available to us.
Out of all the tool box of
all problems we can reach to,
the log has the mildest
sort of singularities.
Singularities at both ends,
which is sort of funny,
but the mildest sort
of singularities
you have to cope with.
So we want to find the
minimum of these unconstrained
optimization problems where the
gradient of f minus mu sum 1
over h, grad h,
is equal to zero.
And we just do that for
progressively smaller values
of mu, and we'll
converge to a solution.
That's the interior
point method.
You use homotopy to study a
sequence of barrier parameters,
or continuation to study a
sequence of barrier parameters.
You stop the homotopy or
continuation when what?
How are you going to stop?
I've got to make
mu small, right?
I want to go towards the
limit mu equals zero.
I can't actually get
to mu equals zero,
I've just got to approach it.
So how small do I need
to make mu before I quit?
It's an interesting question.
What do you think?
I'll take this answer first.
AUDIENCE: So it doesn't
affect the limitation.
JAMES SWAN: Good.
So we might look at
the solution and see
is the solution
becoming less and less
sensitive to the choice of mu.
Did you have another suggestion?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SWAN: Set the tolerance.
Right, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SWAN: Mhm.
Right, right, right, right.
So you--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SWAN: Good.
So there were two
suggestions here.
One is along the lines
of a step-norm criteria,
like I check my
solution as I change mu,
and I ask when does
my solution seem
relatively insensitive to mu.
When the changes in these
steps relative to mu
get sufficiently
small, I might be
willing to accept
these solutions
as reasonable solutions for
the constrained optimization.
I can also go back
and I can check
sort of function norm criteria.
I can take the value of
x I found as the minimum,
and I can ask how
good a job does
it do satisfying the
original equations.
How far away am I from
satisfying the inequality
constraint?
How close am I to actually
minimizing the function
within that domain?
OK.
So we're running
out of time here.
Let me provide you
with an example.
So let's minimize again--
I always pick this function
because it's easy to visualize,
a nice parabolic function
that opens upwards.
And let's minimize it
subject to the constraint
that h of x1 and x2
is equal to 1 minus--
well, the equation for a circle
of radius 1, essentially.
The interior of that circle.
So here's the contours
of the function,
and this red domain
is the constraint.
And we want to know
the smallest value
of f that lives in this domain.
So here's a Matlab code.
You can try it out.
And make a function, the
objective function, f,
it's x squared plus 10x--
x1 squared plus 10x2 squared.
Here's the gradient.
Here's the Hessian.
Here, I calculate h.
Here's the gradient in h.
Here's the Hessian in h.
I've got to define a new
objective function, phi,
which is f minus mu log h.
This is the gradient in phi
and this is the Hessian of phi.
Oh, man, what a mess.
But actually, not such
a mess, because the log
makes it really easy to
take these derivatives.
So it's just a lot of
differential sort of calculus
involved in working this out,
but this is the Hessian of phi.
And then I need
some initial guess.
So I pick the
center of my circle
as an initial guess
for the solution.
And I'm going to loop
over values of mu that
get progressively smaller.
I'll just go down
to 10 to the minus 2
and stop for illustration
purposes here.
But really, we should be
checking the solution as we go
and deciding what values
we want to stop with.
And then this loop
here, what's this do?
What's it do?
Can you tell?
AUDIENCE: Is it Newton?
JAMES SWAN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Newton?
JAMES SWAN: Yeah, it's
Newton-Raphson, right?
x is x minus Hessian inverse
times grad phi, right?
So I just do Newton-Raphson.
I take my initial
guess and I loop around
with Newton-Raphson, and
when this loop finishes,
I reduce mu, and it'll
just use my previous guess
as the initial guess for
the next value of the loop,
until mu is sufficiently small.
OK?
Interior point method.
Here's what that
solution path looks like.
So mu started at 1, and
the barrier was here.
It was close to the edge of the
circle, but not quite on it.
But as I reduced mu
further and further
and further, you
can see the path,
the solution path,
that was followed
works its way closer to
the boundary of the circle.
And the minimum is
found right here.
So it turns out the
minimum of this function
doesn't live in the
domain, it lives
on the boundary of the domain.
Recall that this point
should be a point where
the boundary of the
domain is parallel
to the contours of the function,
since actually we didn't need
the inequality constraint here.
We could have used the
equality constraint.
The equality constrained
problem has the same solution
as the inequality
constrained problem.
And look, that
actually happened.
Here's the contours
of the function.
The contour of the function
runs right along here,
and you can see
it looks like it's
going to be tangent to
the circle at this point.
So the interpoint
method actually solved
an equality constrained problem
in addition to an inequality
constrained problem, which is--
that's sort of cool that you
can do it that way.
How about if I want to do
a combination of equality
and inequality constraints?
Then what do I do?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SWAN: Perfect.
Convert the equality
constraint into unknowns,
Lagrange multipliers, instead.
And then do the
interior point method
on the Lagrange
multiplier problem.
Now you've got a combination
of equality and inequality
constrained.
This is exactly
what Matlab does.
So it converts
equality constraints
into Lagrange multipliers.
Inequality constraints
it actually solves
using interior point methods.
Buried in that
interior point method
is some form of Newton-Raphson
and steepest descent combined
together, like dog
leg we talked about
for unconstrained problems.
And it's going to
do a continuation.
As it reduces the
values of mu, it'll
have some heuristic
for how it does that.
It's going to use its previous
solutions as initial guesses
for the next iteration.
So these are very
complicated problems,
but if you understand how to
solve systems of nonlinear
equations, and you
think carefully
about how to control numerical
error in your algorithm,
you come to a
conclusion like this,
that you can do these sorts of
Lagrange multiplier interior
point methods to solve a
wide variety of problems
with reasonable reliability.
OK?
Any more questions?
No?
Good.
Well, thank you, and
we'll see you on Friday.